welcome back to CBS morning's live shot
from St Louis today a Missouri man named
Lamar Johnson is finally free after
spending more than half of his life in
prison for a murder that two other men
say they committed here's a moment
yesterday that a judge finally set him
free
the motion of the circuit attorney of
the 22nd Judicial Circuit filed herein
for the benefit of Lamar Johnson is
granted
foreign
taking that in 48 hours correspondent
Aaron Moriarty has been following this
case for years Aaron my heart just went
out to him it looks like he didn't even
know how to react it was heartbreaking
to see but also exciting that he's going
to be going home
well Gail I have to I have to admit I've
never seen a full exoneration just like
that so it was very moving you know
we're used to seeing prosecutors put
people in prison but in this case a
prosecutor the St Louis circuit attorney
went to court to free an inmate an
inmate that she believes her own office
put behind bars wrongfully and yesterday
a judge made it happen
[Music]
in a court hallway echoing with Applause
Lamar Johnson took his first steps as a
free man
just two hours earlier Judge David Mason
overturned Lamar Johnson's conviction
for murder a decision that Johnson has
spent half a lifetime waiting for
[Applause]
the Johnson Now 49 years old was only 21
when he was convicted of the murder of
Marcus Boyd Boyd was shot to death in
October 1994 by two men wearing face
masks is that I didn't kill commit more
kill Marcus I didn't have anybody go
kill Marcus I had no reason whatsoever
to kill Marcus but the only eyewitness
to the shooting Greg alkene identified
Johnson as one of the shooters last
December at a week-long innocence
hearing Elkin admitted that he had lied
at Johnson's trial he testified that he
was unable to identify anyone out of two
lineups but he felt pressured to help
investigators I I hate talking about it
they telling it Elkin's identification
led to Johnson's conviction he later
recanted and came forward to make things
right and I've been living with him
for 30 25 28 years I just wish I could
change time judge Mason found elk
incredible as he did this Man convicted
killer James Howard who calmly admitted
under oath that he and another man were
the shooters who killed Marcus Boyd How
did Marcus die
[Music]
this is the first time a prosecutor in
St Louis circuit Attorney Kim Gardner
went to court to set a man free her
effort was opposed by the state's
attorney general we asked Johnson in
October what he was most looking forward
to If released
time there are relationships and the
bond that I could have created with my
daughters
with my mother
that's something I'll never ever be able
to give back
and I am just trying to you know
I'm looking forward to
making the best use of the time that we
have left
and that's what I want to do
so Lamar will have time but that's about
it at age 49 he's starting all over
without money without compensation but
he does have a date to look forward to
because he was released in time to walk
his youngest daughter down the aisle at
our wedding this spring so there is some
good news about this
Nate
that just gave me goosebumps yeah it is
good to hear that that there's something
positive to come out of this but I want
to go back to Aaron where you said no
compensation the only thing the state
can do is just say sorry this man gets
nothing
well there is an effort in the
legislature finally to try to get
compensation for people who are remember
he was exonerated it wasn't just that
his conviction was overturned he was
exonerated found actually innocent so
there is an effort but right now the
only inmates who are entitled to
compensation here in Missouri are people
who are freed based on DNA evidence but
I think I I think that's one of the
reasons why I'm raising this I think
people should know about this yeah Aaron
are there lessons here for the way the
system works and putting innocent people
away
I'm sorry I Tony I I didn't hear are
there lessons here for improving are
there lessons here for improving the
justice system so more innocent people
are not put away
oh Tony yes everything in this case
really shows how easy it is for someone
to get convicted and then how hard to
get that conviction overturned so there
was bad eyewitness testimony there was a
use of a snitch it was incredible
um when you look at the worst things
that happen at a trial it happened in
Lamar Johnson's case and this is a man
who fought for 28 years he filed appeal
after Appeal on his own Pro Se because
he couldn't afford an attorney and
justices judges often ignore those and
this is also a lesson to pay more
attention to those filings that that
just makes me even matter to hear it I
just want to end on a note about Mr
Johnson he seems so calm and so measured
considering all that he's been through
what's he like Aaron and what happens to
him now
uh you know what Gail that is one of the
reasons why I've stayed on this story he
has always been that way he's always
believed that he was going to get out
ultimately and that hope seemed to keep
him very calm
um he's so excited to get his life back
and and to now become a real father to
his two daughters he stayed in touch
with his family so that it's a good
thing
and let us learn from Lamar's
perspective all we have is time yeah
Aaron thank you so much